bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france
il faut prolonger l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en france
en quelque sorte je ne sais pas ce que
ça veut dire pour nous l'état d'urgence
sanitaire nous sommes en état d'urgence
de fait nous avons besoin qu'on met à
notre disposition les moyens nécessaires
pour les soigner pas que craignent les
libertés fondamentales
c'est à dire c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement octroie des
pouvoirs particuliers unifa n'a pas
franchement excès jusqu'à présent qu'est
ce que vous souhaiteriez vous de
l'appartement des autorités dans cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire
quand j'ai déjà dit lors d'une pression
interview j'ai pas franchement d'espoir
sur une demande que je peux comprendre
aux autorités ils sont tellement dans le
mensonge voit aujourd'hui que je
souhaitais quelque chose de la part des
autorités ma paraît illusoire
ce qu'il faudrait faire à mon avis déjà
c'est ne plus mentir à l'ensemble de la
population sur l'état réel de la cible
est à savoir premièrement le risque
sanitaire est toujours extrêmement
présents en pour l'antarctique et pour
les enfants et le la sécurité sanitaire
des enfants dans ce qu'ils reviendront à
l'école des enfants et des enseignants
ne me semble pas assurée il faut
demander mon avis aux syndicats
d'enseignants agitant pense mais j'ai
vraiment l'impression que les futurs
hits et sanitaire des enfants n'est pas
assurée en tout cas moi je mettrais pas
mes enfants à l'école
commente l'usm chose comment vous avez
une chose oui pardon excusez moi les y
penser mais c'est l'histoire du match
tient
les buts qu'il ya une polémique en ce
moment sur sur les distribution de
masques nous nous sommes à rationner en
hqe depuis le début de l'épidémie
nous avons perdu des collègues qui sont
décédées du fait d'une contamination et
aujourd'hui on nous annonce un grand
renfort de publicité que des centaines
de millions de macs ont des frites et
moi distribué dans la grande
distribution et chez c'est vraiment
scandaleux
je voudrais vous entendre sur ce dernier
point mais pour revenir justement sur le
retour des écoliers dans les
établissements et pourtant le conflit un
conseil scientifique quand même un qui
collaborent avec les autorités sur ce
point là donc vous vous dites qu'il faut
pas que les élèves reviennent à l'école
le conseil scientifique il là il me
semblait qu'il avait préconisé que la
rentrée se fait alors comment comment
expliquer justement cette décision du
gouvernement ce pour des raisons
économiques
oui tout à fait il veut remettre le
français au travail alors les mains sur
les enfants de maternelle en premier les
gars qui veulent utiliser l'école comme
garderie les masques donc vous l'avez
dit il devrait être vendu massivement
dans les grandes surfaces à partir de
lundi alors même que les personnels
enseignants dénoncent une pénurie au
niveau des hôpitaux
ça c'est encore une nouvelle polémique
un nouveau scandale
bien sûr le mensonge
je suis quelque chose qui est devient la
marque de ce gouvernement sur les matchs
de chz a été vraiment
au delà de tout ce qui pouvait être
imaginales à mon avis un mois je suis
très en colère surtout du fait de mes
collègues étaient contaminés certains
décédés et qu' il n'y a pas eu de
protection sur mes collègues libéraux
sur sol et les malades aussi été
insultée sur les les gens qui étaient
porteurs probablement qu'ils ont dû
circuler et répandre le virus
aujourd'hui on nous dit il va y avoir de
match 14 ans du transport en commun et
jusqu'à présent il me semblait que le
gouvernement direction savait rien de
tout ça fait que j'avais une colère très
importante et qui n'a pas séché au
contraire parmi les conditionnalités
d'un déconfinement réussi entre
guillemets il ya aussi des tests
là quels sont vos observations c'est la
même chose pour contenir une épidémie
moi je suis pas infectiologues je suis
peut être que des biologistes mais il me
semble que des choses de bon sens qui
devrait être fait
le gouvernement s'est vu proposer par un
certain nombre de laboratoires français
la réalisation de tests qu'il a refusé
et les tests à grande échelle n'ont pas
été réalisés ne sont toujours pas
réalisés
merci beaucoup olivier vernet neurologue
au centre hospitalier de gonesse